So most of us think that information is
the best way to convince people of our
truth and in fact it doesn't work that
well and we see that all the time,
right?
We see it where with climate change,
where there's tons of data suggesting
that climate change is manmade,
but about 50 percent of the population
doesn't believe it or with people
arguing about things like how many
people were in the neck in the
presidential inauguration.
So we have facts,
but people decide which facts they want
to listen to,
which facts they want to take and change
their opinions in which they want to
disregard.
And one of the reasons for this is when
something doesn't confirm to what I
already believe,
what people tend to do is either
disregard it or rationalize it away
because information doesn't take into
account what makes us human,
which is our emotions,
our desires,
our motives,
and our prior beliefs.
So for example,
in one study my colleagues and I tried
to see whether we could use science to
change people's opinions about climate
change.
The first thing we did was ask people,
do you believe in manmade climate
change?
Do you support the Paris agreement?
And based on their answers,
we divided them into the strong
believers and the weak believers.
And then we gave them information for
some people.
We said that scientists have reevaluated
the data and now conclude the things are
actually much worse than they thought
before that the temperature would rise
by about seven degrees to 10 degrees.
For some people,
we said the scientists have reevaluated
data and they now believe that actually
the situation is not as bad as I
thought.
Um,
it's much better and the rise in
temperature would be quite small.
And what we found is that people who did
not believe in climate change when they
heard that the scientists are saying,
actually it's not that bad.
Um,
they changed their beliefs even more in
that direction.
So they became more extremists in that
direction.
But when they hear that,
the scientists think it's much worse,
they didn't nudge.
And the people who already believe that
climate change is manmade.
When they heard that things are
actually,
scientists are saying are much worse
than they did before.
They moved more in that direction,
so they became more polarized,
but when they heard that the scientists
are saying it's not that bad.
They didn't touch much.
So we gave people information and as a
result it caused polarization.
It didn't cause people to come together.
So the question is what's happening
inside our brain that causes this?
And in one study,
my colleagues and I scanned brain
activity of two people who were
interacting and what we found was when
those two people agreed on a question
that we gave them,
the brain was really encoding what the
other person was saying,
the details that they gave.
But when the two people disagreed,
it looked metaphorically as if the brain
was switching off and not encoding what
the other person was saying.
And as a result,
when the two agreed,
they became even more confident.
But when they disagreed,
there wasn't as much of a change in
their confidence in their own view.
What has been shown by [inaudible] and
colleagues from Yale University is that
the more intelligent you are,
the more likely you are in fact,
to change data at will.
So what they did is they first gave
participants in their experiment,
I'm analytical,
a math questions to solve,
and then they gave them data about gun
control,
is gun control actually reducing
violence.
And they found that more intelligent
people actually were more likely to
twist data at will to make it conform to
what they already believed.
So it seems that people are using their
intelligent,
not necessarily to find the truth,
but to take in the information and
change it to conform to what they
already believe.
So,
um,
yeah,
so that suggests that just giving people
information without considering first
where they're coming from may backfire
at us.
Um,
but we don't always need to go against
someone's conviction in order to change
their behavior.
And let me give you an example for this
is a study that was conducted at Ucla,
um,
were what they wanted to do is convince
parents to vaccinate their kids.
And some of the parents didn't want to
vaccinate their kids because they were
afraid of the link with autism.
So they had two approaches.
First they said,
well,
the link with autism is actually not
meal.
Here's all the data suggesting there
isn't a link between vaccines and
autism.
And it didn't really work that well,
but instead they use another approach.
So instead of going that way,
they used another approach which is,
let's not talk about autism.
We don't necessarily need to talk about
autism to convince you to vaccinate your
kid.
Instead they said,
well look,
these vaccines protect kids from deadly
diseases right from the measles.
And they showed them pictures of what
the measles are.
Because in this argument about vaccines,
people actually forgot what the vaccines
are for,
what are they protecting us from?
And they highlighted that and didn't
necessarily go on to discuss autism.
And that had a much better outcome for
the parents were much more likely to
say,
yes,
we are going to vaccinate our kids.
So the lesson here is that we need to
find the common motives.
The common motives in this case was the
health of the children,
right?
Not necessarily going back to the the
thing that they were arguing about that
they disagreed about.